France's interior Minister has ordered a
large deployment of security forces
around Paris as angry farmers threaten
to head toward the protesting farmers
vow to encircle Paris with tractor
barricades as they battle with the
government over the future of their
industry the country's Prime Minister
sought but failed to  diffuse the farmers
movement last week with a series of
proagriculture measures however farmers
say they short of their demands that
producing food be more creative easier and
more
era my we are here today we are leaving
the highway for the first time in
almost 8 days  we take the 31 and this
evening we decided to come back here here we
go a little further and we cringe and we
clang and we talk about the 4% we talk about
commercial negotiations we talk about
imports we talk about breeding we
talk about
farmers are speaking badly of
all that and for the moment it is a very
light
announcement, we are here because we are
frankly dissatisfied with the
current policy regarding agriculture,
in particular we are subject to standards which
prevent us from  to work and which
makes us lower production
so Mac
gives us more realistic standards
or even more standards so we would still be
there it would still be a nice
step forward in any case it's about time it's
really about time it's about time
for everyone, whether for all
countries, it is time for things to change
and I think that we took
strong action here, we rarely got on
the highways like that to say that we
were not happy and to deviate
a whole whole organization and and so
we are at the door of Brussels so
of course we will have colleagues from
other countries who will
also arrive and and so in a way they
are obliged to do something  thing we're
not going to leave we're not going to leave in not
satisfied that's it's it's not possible
but seeing a little bit that it's
starting that it's starting in
other countries well we say to ourselves well that's it
maybe  come together so that we
will be stronger towards Europe
and we would like Europe to take
its
responsibilities